[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Jake is
in De Mo Iowa hi Jake how are you hey
guys it's an honor to speak with you
thanks for having me our pleasure how
can we help sir yeah so I'm 35 years old
have no debt and am about to step into
baby step six and my question is uh you
talk about uh baby step seven living in
giving like no one else I have no
problem with the the giving aspect of
things the part that is a little tricky
for me to wrap my mind around is the
living like no one else because uh I am
a pastor and so to be stepping into baby
step seven hopefully here in the next
five or six years I'm trying to imagine
life in my 40s living like no one else
while being a pastor and and living in
the community of people who uh who pay
for who have paid for my uh financial
success you could say I I don't know how
else you you would put it but how how
should I think through that as I look
forward to the next five or 10 years
yeah well
um don't muzzle the ox as he Treads out
the grain you probably read that
scripture right yeah and a worker is
worthy of his
hire you probably read that scripture
right so are you a good pastor and
you're worth what they pay
you I I sure hope so okay then if you
use that money wisely in Christianity we
would call that good stewardship
wouldn't
we I think you're modeling for those
people what good Steward what the
results of good stewardship are that it
ends up with
wealth but we're taught by
the by Carl Marx not by Jesus that
wealth is
evil wealth is not evil people are
evil particularly some of them in your
church I'm kidding no
but but uh not much but yeah
anyway but yeah but but so you're always
going to have a hater whether you win or
you lose if you do it at
scale yeah if you lose you weren't a
good Steward and you're horrible and you
worked your whole life and you have
nothing to show for it and we call that
being a good Steward that's not a good
Steward that means you did a bad job
handling your
money so you're supposed to model for
your congregation how to how to be a
good husband how to be a good dad right
right how to be a great leader we're
supposed to model in Christian it's
called a witness we call And yet when it
my my friend Craig Rochelle says why is
it that wealth is the only blessing from
God we're supposed to apologize
for and I've got several friends that
are pastors that are uh a decade and a
half ahead of you and they're facing the
exact same thing CU they have
systematically carefully invested in uh
in their 401ks and in their Roth IRAs
and in their retirement programs and
some of them have bought real estate
carefully and they they don't have jet
airplanes they're not on TV you know
that it's none of that junk they're just
good guys as a pastor and they've been
careful with their income and most of
them are millionaires because they did
the stuff I teach but now there's always
some duber that says well Pastor should
never be a millionaire yeah that's what
I want I want my pastor to be broke and
stupid no I don't either I want my P I
don't want I want you know Pastor should
never listen I want my pastor I want his
marriage to be something I can look up
to I want his kids to be something I can
look up to I want the way he handles
money to be something I can look up to
because obviously the book he is reading
has having an effect on his life and I
want to know more about what that book
called The Bible says then but not if
you're out you know so but you're always
going to be criticized Jake whether it's
about your message or the car you drive
there going to be someone out there ex
and you know you have to get
if you're a Christian you have to drive
a used Accord cuz that's what Jesus said
they were all in one Accord oh that one
still gets me this is the Ramsey Show